hey good morning everybody it's Mike
it's uh Sunday morning it's about 10
o'clock uh central time thanks for uh
everyone that came out on sort of you
know this short notice I know it's uh
coming into Thanksgiving week and you
know it's it's going to be uh kind of a
abbreviated trading week with the
holiday and all but uh again you know
thanks for taking the time out this
morning to to join us and what I want to
talk about today is you know we have
this new indicator called the value
scalper and it's really a
in my opinion it's a great tool because
it looks at things in the order flow
that not
a lot of people are really looking at
right most people were that use the
order flow they're they're just looking
at you know the Deltas the point of
control
um imbalances and you know the
relationships between them whereas
you know value is something that I think
a lot of Traders need to pay attention
to and
the whole concept of value you know it
goes back to
um Market profile in the sense of you
know looking at the day's value but you
could actually break it down further
into you know smaller sections you know
intraday as opposed to If you're looking
at the market profile you're looking at
the entire day's profile
um seeing how value is developing
but with order flow now that you know
where the volume is coming in and how
it's trading you can determine value on
a much shorter time frame and you know
most footprint charts you know this is
what they look like it's just your
normal bid ask volume as well as your
point of control
and you know you got your Delta you got
your imbalances and you know one of the
things that we added a while back over a
year ago in the order flows Trader is
being able to see where the value areas
are in a bar
and in my opinion you know that that
really opened up a whole new way for
Traders to look at the market you know
now some software that they will have
you could actually draw a profile like
on a bar chart you know of that
individual bar which you know is is
similar to what we're doing here again
we're not you know
inventing something new or just taking a
concept that already exists out there
and using it on the order flow right on
on a shorter time frame and once you
start adding the value right that's
these boxes around
um you know in each bar the bigger boxes
you know each bar has the point of
control but each bar also has a value
area and there's information that
Traders can use from
the value areas to determine you know
are you balancing and you know have you
found value but more importantly when
markets start to move away from
established value
okay because that's what the markets do
right they they look for area to balance
and rotate around which is your value
and again values is let's say a moving
Target but value is always being
reassessed right
re-adjusted based on the current
information that's coming into the
market right you know the information
coming into the market it's like a it's
like a hose right of water you know
there's always
new water coming in in this case there's
always new information coming into the
market that
Traders can use to reassess the market
you know value
is not static and you know I've talked
about this in the past you know with
things like a flexible volume profile
um you know where you can anchor it from
you know swing highs or swing lows and
you know find how value is developing
because you know we all know that
when
you know just in recent history right I
mean the last few months you know CPI is
a big number so once the CPI number
comes out everything in the past you
know prior to you know 729 and earlier
that they doesn't really hold much water
for the rest of the trading day and if
you're looking at a
profile for the day well you're taking
into account a lot of information
that really has no bearing on what's
happening right now in the market or for
example if you know someone from the FED
is is talking you know and they say
something about rates from that moment
on the rest of the day what happened
earlier doesn't really carry much weight
in the market but if you're
basing your analysis on you know
everything that happened even prior to
when you know the Fed
guy speaks and and makes something you
know a change in Direction about the FED
that information
isn't very useful to you now anymore
right so by looking at value
on a much smaller time frame then you're
going to be able to in my opinion make
better decisions based off of what is
happening right now okay so again you
know once you start adding the value
areas on your chart then you can start
seeing you know where value is
overlapping over bars you know you're
balancing basically
but it's those times where you know the
market starts to break out of balance
and starts to move in a Direction that's
where those Trends are going to happen
right I mean here you know we're sort of
balancing right in here you see these
value areas mostly overlapping over here
they're mostly overlapping now they're
starting to break out right and then you
see the market breaks down into these
new lows now
what we've done is we've created this
tool called the value scalper okay and
you know this is just really brief this
is from the user guide
markets spend most of their time trading
around value
our value is not static it's constantly
being readjusted based on the Traders
perceptions of the market when a market
is efficient Traders perceptions values
are in line with the true underlying
value however these inefficiencies can
cause traders to misperceive Value which
leads to disequilibrium in the markets
and it's at this equilibrium that cause
markets
to move right you want to be able to
take advantage of when there's at this
equilibrium occurring in the market
because you know most of the time
markets just you know they sort of do
this they overlap the value overlap the
value but what you want to be doing as a
Trader is taking advantage of those
times of this equilibrium in the market
and
this is a uh so this is I'm going to
show it to you on a bar chart because
the
order flows the value scalper right from
order flows it works on a footprint
chart as well as a bar chart you know
your normal Candlestick chart you do
need to have tick replay if you want to
see it you know on the in you know on
past data but if you have tick replay
off it'll start calculating from the
moment you open your chart so it's not
required but if you want to look at it
you know to the left of the chart then
you're going to need to replay enabled
now let me just uh make it a little bit
bigger to see here so you know I've
added it in here right order flows value
scalper you can see down here and
um
the default setting is two but let me
make these triangles a little bit bigger
so it's a little bit easier to see
um because it might be a little bit hard
on your screen
okay and comply
so I'll make it 15
. now
just really quick about some of these
settings there's a swing filter right
which on default is disabled uh swing
period if you're using the swing filter
you could enter whatever value you like
default is one but swing filter is
disabled now there's a minimum bar
volume required if it's set at zero
which is the default it means it's just
ignoring the bar volume but again you
know some Traders like to trade
more illiquid markets and you know
some of these markets you know for
example soybean meal May trade
you know on average on a minute-based
chart 50 contracts but sometimes it's
going to trade five contracts so by
setting a minimum bar volume required to
say 20 it will ignore those bars that
have extremely light volume if you're
Trading
you know e-minis things like that liquid
markets the normal markets you don't
have to worry about that setting now
there's a power mode which I'll talk
about and there's
the value level there's three levels one
two and three one is basically the
minimum two is sort of average three is
the most stringent
and
there's this signal mode there's live
and confirmed just leave it on confirmed
meaning the bars would have to close for
it to Signal live
you know it can show it and and unshow
it then obviously you have a sound alert
and that's basically it as far as the
settings the main settings are the value
level and power mode and swing filter
I'm going to talk about you know how to
use those three so this is
value level two this is the default
right when you first install it and open
it up you see the default is set to two
Okay which is you know sort of the
average and again just click apply and
if you're running tick replay you'll see
it just takes
a couple seconds for it to to start up
so
let's get uh going here you see it says
calculating okay so again right out of
the box this is the default setting of
two with no swing filter this is on the
e-mini from from Friday okay let me get
the crosshairs on let's make it a little
bit uh
a little bit darker here as you can see
it's across here
looking is that the two okay
all right
so the triangles okay the up and down
triangles the down one is the cell the
up one is a buy now again this is
setting at two with no swing filter if
you have it at the minimum
you know people can say what's the
difference between one two and three
obviously at the minimum of one
you're going to get more signals right
higher you go to you're gonna get less
and three being the most stringent
you'll get
you know fewer than two and and fewer
than three now you can see here that
honestly that there's not much
difference when you're looking at some
of these markets of one two and three I
mean between one and two is not going to
be much difference in between two and
three but obviously between one and
three there's going to be some more
differences
um I know that just really quick if
we're just sort of focusing on this move
here right you can see
from 152 right there's that buy then
there's a couple buys up here a sell and
a buy if you were to change it to say
two okay just sort of keep our eye on
that area
okay right there was a buy here remember
there's a couple buys up here a cell and
another buy there you'll see there's
going to be slightly
less signals okay so you can see just
the buy here
um nothing else on the way up so it's
sort of you know by making the value
level more
I'll say stronger but you know a higher
level it's going it's just being more
strict on what it's looking for in terms
of uh value right in giving signals now
obviously if we go to the highest level
of three
I don't say the highest level but you
know the most
stringent level which is actually the
level that I've always used you know in
my own calculations of of trading is
using that
you can see there's you know you don't
even have the buy you just got those
cells here so you're seeing you know the
cell the cell the buy the cell and these
three little cells there now
again now I realize not everybody trades
Equity indices right and
you know sometimes I I get emails from
people say ah you know what Mike I'm
struggling trading you know I'm trading
NASDAQ or mnq and these these markets
are volatile I'm like like why put
yourself in this position to trade these
markets that are
very volatile right why don't you trade
something that's you know a bit less
volatile we're reading the order flow is
a bit easier and I'm always suggest you
know things that are more driven
by supply and demand
then you know a lot of other factors
right the way that equities are are
driven by a lot of factors
um you know for example you know what
happens in Bitcoin crap out you know two
or three percent it's gonna it's gonna
weigh on the equity indices right it
just there's a lot of other factors
sometimes that that have these effects
on
you know the stock indices That You
Don't See in other markets I mean you
know I like to trade you know
Commodities obviously you know things
like the grain complex
um gold even copper is a nice contract
to trade
um you know obviously you got things
like crude obviously bonds and
currencies so let's just take a look at
um you know some of these other markets
right Ultra bonds UB right great
contract
and it's one of these contracts that
again not a lot of
foreign
but you know a lot of this money that's
that comes in and goes out very fast you
know these are you know people that
trade some of these contracts you know
there's a reason they trade it to have
to right because they got you know these
massive portfolios you don't necessarily
see a lot of that rampant speculation
that you would see in you know mnq right
because people's
see somebody that's trading mnq on on
Twitter and then they post a screenshot
of oh I made 70 points in the mnq today
well yeah because it's a very volatile
Market you know what would you rather
have something you know I'll say
something slow and steady but you know
think of the the hair and the turtle
right that old kid's tail all right slow
and steady wins the race all right and
the same thing comes with trading you
know if you're talking about some of
these moves here like this move down
this move back up here's a nice move
down
um you know here's a nice move up I know
people will send me a screenshot of this
later say oh well yeah it had this bad
trade here I had this badge right here
well it shouldn't be taking this one
this is the the trade you should be
taking here
move down a little move up a little move
down but again you know that's yesterday
um here it is even in the evening
session the overnight the European hours
um nice move down a little move up nice
move down
you know it's not all about you know
just chasing after the market because
somebody posted a big screenshot
thinking you can do it as well you know
sometimes it's better to trade these
markets where
order flow
follows you know the markets follow the
order flow much better because at the
end of the day you know order flow is
supply and demand
right in these bigger markets you know
these Bond markets these commodity
markets are really more driven by supply
and demand as opposed to you know having
a lot of speculative money coming into
the market this was the day before
nice moves down nice moves up down up
down up down up
you know even in the evening session a
little move up nice little move down
come on move up nice move down
you know just going back
you know the day before right because I
don't want to show you one chart and
think oh you know Mike's just cherry
picking
well you know this is the this is the
Wednesday right I showed you Friday
after showed you Thursday so you know
this is Wednesday this is just a simple
one minute chart right a one minute
chart with the setting
value level set at three right nothing
else okay but I want to get into some of
these swing filters
like the swing filter and the power mode
I mean look at this if you just catch
this one trade here or even this trade
here you'll be done for the day you
don't need to bang your head against the
wall all day long right look at this
European hours
gives you the signal right before the
Big Bar down but then on the move back
up
you know you're talking 131 14 15 all
the way up to I don't see the figure but
you know at least up into here where it
pauses you know a quick 10 points
um the day before right the Tuesday look
at that nice sharp move up
to move down they move down they move
down they move up we will move down to
move up
you know this one probably would have
stopped you out here but the move down
here but again that was on
um I think that's CPI day
and again during the evening session I
know some people say I I got a job I got
to work I can't trade
during the daytime but I can get up
early again you know
there you are right looking at Value in
the evening sessions the overnight or
early morning sessions
use some great trades opportunities
right I mean take a look at the gold
market gold on here
now gold is a little bit uh
a little bit volatile at times okay and
you can see right again this is Friday
again your standard one minute chart all
right it's a nice move down from you
know 53 down to
you know basically 50 down in here it's
a nice little moves down little moves up
but
look at during the overnight sessions
right
yeah you gotta buy here that did nothing
that stopped you off but it came after a
nice little cell here a nice cell here a
nice buy buy will just take you out here
before it rallied
um a cell you know some cells in here
now
let's talk about some of the other
settings okay so swing filter okay now
setting it to one when you enable the
swing filter is basically the minimum
amount that
of recent history you could look at so
it's going to look back basically the
bar before it and again with the setting
of three
being the the most stringent
um it's probably going to be not many
signals right as you can see here right
it moves up you know there's a move down
to move down
um coming in here
a little move up a little move down
some buys that failed now what I would
recommend is if you're going to use the
swing filter
since you're already filtering out
trades
what I suggest you know depending on the
market that you're trading is set the
value level to the lowest level first
right until you find it comfortable
because if I have a swing filter turned
off and I got it set at one oh you can
see I'm going to see a lot of signals
right
a lot and for some people honestly I
know some people they love to trade you
know in and out in and out they're fine
with that set at one
on a volatile Market but if you're going
to use a swing filter to filter out
trades
you can start with
the value level set at one with the
swing filter
okay
and you see here how it cleans it up
right so now you've seen these cells by
the cell this by the cell
some buys you know here's a nice buy
down here
because as you go a little bit higher up
in terms of value level right if I go to
foreign
larger value area to analyze
there's going to be
less signals okay
you can see in here right
let me just make this smaller
all right so you can see there's fewer
signals than there were when it was set
at
one and obviously three
is going to give you even less signals
okay
now
one again is is the minimum if you're
using a swing filter
people ask me what levels I like to use
you know I like to use one three five
and I used to use nine but I just find
nine just just gets pretty far out but
you know setting it at
levels of say
one three or five
in my opinion is is good enough
okay so here you see it now it's set at
five so it's it's giving you you know
less signals
but
you know it's up to you to determine you
know if you how you want to use it right
if you wanted if I had to set at three
it'll give me
slightly it should give me slightly more
signals
right I think there was this buy that
popped in here
um I think this by
I think that buy popped in but it's
going to give you you know a little bit
more but I would start at one and swing
filter of one value level of one
um if you're going to start doing your
own research on you know what sort of
um
swing filter and value level combination
you know you you want to use and again
you know that's on you know a simple one
minute chart you know if you're using
something you know a tick based chart
you know 100 right I'm just picking it
out
random
um you know a 100 tick chart I don't
know what it looks like on gold but just
give it a second here so okay so it's
come up what did I have my settings at
um
swing filter of one anytime I open up a
new chart I just start it at Value level
three no swing filter
and go from there right because I might
not need to use a swing filter right I
mean
a 100 tick chart you know works out to
about a
anywhere between you know a 30 second
chart
it's sort of a sub one minute chart
okay you can see you know these are the
signals right and again you just sort of
go back to you know the other Market
that we just looked at
um Ultra Bonds on the same type of chart
uh 100 ticks
again so this is the ultra Bonds on 100
tick you know also looks pretty decent
um now
you know just
pick out some of these other you know
look at wheat you know wheat I've always
had sort of a fondness for wheat this is
a 100 tick chart
again when you're on a tick based chart
on
some of these grains over you know from
8 30
reopen
going back to the reopen of five
you're not going to get very many bars
and that's just how it is with those
with the grains because it just doesn't
really trade much you can see here this
one's got a bit more of activity this is
8 30. you had that but like on this day
you know you're talking 8 30 here to
here
um
the grains again yeah for things like
wheat I actually like um
a shorter tick chart you know I like 40
honestly
um
for things like grains and and meal and
Grains like wheat
beans and meal you know like see it's
pretty decent right nice look at this
whole Trend up
right
pauses a little bit comes down goes back
up right keeping you along just as down
here selling off
Market rallies you got your buy signals
Market sells off got your sell signals
um
let's go to you know the normal one
minute chart
foreign
here
again you know this is just how it
looked now you know people ask me about
currencies sometimes you know it's a
good currency British pound I like
um euro currency obviously I like
I think as far as currencies I mean the
two main ones that I follow British
pound in euro currency a certain extent
Japanese Yen I mean you could get some
nice Moves In in Japanese Yen
but there's times where it's kind of us
in my opinion a bit slow so you can see
here right this is you know British
pound again all I'm doing is just the
same setting of three now I'm going to
do is I'm going to show you this power
mode
okay so power mode on
and I'll keep it at three
but honestly at three with the power
mode power mode is just trying to find a
stronger sort of this
when we're doing the
analysis for the value area we just sort
of found these you know certain times
there's these I don't know what you want
to call it sort of these this
combination of a few factors
taking place and
so you know that's what the power mode
is now this is it set at
three right the highest level so you see
this nice sharp move up you know this
one that failed here's one that failed
there's one that failed
not too encouraging but again that's
with it set at the highest level of
three
um
set it for one to start
okay so you see it's getting you in this
is again the British pound you know
is nice to trade during the European
hours obviously it's the
it's the it's the currency in
England didn't catch anything on this
mode but you know he got this late
little move up but again you're not
gonna get involved at two in the
afternoon but during the the European
hours nice moves here to be had up and
down
you know go back sort of the previous
day right
it's a nice
move down right you see it's just all
littered with the sell signals on this
move down
and I'll take a look at something else
go back to uh
gold
okay gold is
this is the gold with the power mode on
right you see this yesterday right or
not yesterday Friday
it's a nice move down it's a nice move
up
um you know this is
again
people sort of get
I would say lost but you know they sort
of think oh you know the overnight
markets aren't worth trading they are
there's there's very good moves to be
had in the overnight session on a lot of
markets okay this is gold
see during the day session
on gold
sometimes you don't get a lot of a lot
of Trades
at night right you've seen some decent
trades coming in here right look at this
we just caught this move 74
you know down into you know the mid 60s
right these are those moves that you
know you only need to catch that and
you're done for the day you don't need
to trade anymore the rest of the day
um
you know even some markets like uh
I don't know let's pop again you know I
spent a lot of time I don't want to say
bashing the mnq but
mnq at night you know I know people say
oh there's no liquidity at night well
let's
take a look you know I've got power the
power mode on again I've got it set at
one
you know this is the day time but let's
just go back to the evening time you
know the early mornings
you know some nice moves here nice move
down there
um
let's go back you know sort of the
previous day you know here's the move
from doesn't look like much because
these moves are so
so vast in terms of areas covering but
you know let's call it here this is 735
right down here where it sort of bounces
up to you know call it 680.
and there's 50 points right there
on that move then another move down here
gives you the the long here that that
fails and then you're coming into that
into the day session uh
you know going back
so is this I don't know what day this
was the 16th you know
there's a move down there's nothing
really happening here a small move uh
here small move down here
um you know even uh let's take a look at
rty I got rty on here
again this is with the power mode right
I mean again I do know a lot of people
you know want to trade in the evening
want to be Trading
outside of the US hours and I do have a
lot of clients that trade you know
they're based in Europe or they're based
in Asia
right this is Russell okay now again
this is with it set at the the minimum
level of one
ready to catch this move here just catch
this move here
all right honestly I'd much rather trade
this type of moving Market
than this one or a big move up big move
down big move up big move down I'd
rather be trading a market that moves
nicer and when you're looking at Value
right
value is basically the market
determining what it's worth here it
looks like Mark is so unsure of what
it's worth right because it just spikes
up spikes down looks like it's going up
going down it's hard to you know to
trade it's nice to trade if you're
positioned on the right side but
honestly I'd rather trade a market
that's moving like this
than a market that's moving like that
right I mean you're still getting
relatively the same moves but here it's
much more orderly much you know much
easier to trade in my opinion
you know this is the night before right
I mean look at these shorts in here yeah
some small Longs but then you know a
nice big Trend here 50 you know just
call it here 52
all the way down to where you get your
Buy Signal down here in the 30s
okay
now
we do also have what's on here it's
called the trade entry signal and for
those of you that you know aren't
familiar with the trade entry signal is
you see it's set at two and two and it's
enabled on by default so what it is
basically is
it's telling me that
the conditions are met in a bar
and then there's follow through order
flow over the next two bars so basically
it means for a long to signal for this
triangle the signal
I have to have a bullish signal okay so
for a blue triangle for a bullish signal
to appear
conditions are met
and it has to move two ticks over the
next two bars in that direction so
meaning
right this is my signal bar
within the next two bars one two it has
to move at least two ticks above this
high
or a long trade to be signaled just as
here right you got your down triangle
this is my signal bar it has to move two
ticks below the low of that signal bar
within the next two bars but as soon as
it moves then it prints
okay and it's there it won't reprint
just as here right this is my signal bar
but you see the signal appears
the bar afterwards the bar that moves
the two ticks right and where do you
place your stop is just above that high
of that signal bar or below the low of
the signal bar for a buy
and you know in case you're wondering
you know why like here the conditions
were met in this bar
but there's no blue triangle because
it's a Blue Zone
meaning that the market didn't move any
higher
than the high of the bar with the signal
I didn't go too ticks over the next two
bars higher
and subsequently what happened you know
three bars
four bars later it did start to trade up
and then it sold off right so that would
have been a stop this is why we put the
trade entry signal in there is because
not only when you take a trade on order
flow
foreign
flow right because if you don't get if
you're getting long and you don't have
follow-through buying
then there's nothing to keep the market
going up it's just going to fall over
right
which is what happened here just as if
there was say a short let me find one
all right so again trade entry signal
keeps you out of this poor long
keeps out of these Longs here which
Market fellow fell down fell down but
these shorts down here right it looks
like Market wanted to go shorter and it
didn't
this is your signal bar but then the
next bar trades up right that's not a
trade you want to take
right if if I have
the trade entry signal
disabled
okay
you can see there's sell signals here
here you don't want these trades because
these trades as soon as you take them
you're stopped out you're stopped out
right you're stopped out you're stopped
out
that's what the trade entry signal does
it keeps you out of those trades where
there's no follow-through
order flow
okay
all right so that's you know what is
this marketers
um Russell let's just go back to
just go back to the regular es chart
right the e-minis um what did I have it
said I think I get the power mode still
turned on
let me just uh disable that real quick
and it will sort of talk about here turn
this off and I'll keep it back at three
okay
somebody told me about the again you
know I I don't I just I'm a simple
Trader right I trade
one minute charts 30 second charts
um
you know and pick based charts sometimes
I do delve into volume base charts but
you know there's enough to keep me
active with time-based charts
um so we got a few users that are big
users of hikingashi now you can't use
um
wrinkle charts because rental charts you
need tick replay Okay so
it's not going to work there but I can
ask she charts
again I'm not
a hikanashi expert or anything like that
um I I have users that use
hikanashi charts and
you know they'll always send me his
charts with my indicators on it and you
know sometimes I'm
quite Blown Away on some of these things
so this is you know the simple high
kanashi this is with it set at what is
that set at three
okay I mean if you use the just the
default set at two again tick replay on
um
and just the value level there's no
other swing filter there's no other
power mode or or volume
filter
okay so you can see here right it's
giving you these little logs these
shorts these Longs these shorts
um you know this long here
so this is the default setting of two
right just the default I set it at one
obviously there'll be much more signals
here it is in the evening session
right and that's what I talk about when
I when I mean
you know there's a lot of outside
factors affecting the trade that's going
on in markets like e-minis there's a lot
of sideways action in here but you know
overnight you don't necessarily get a
lot of that
those funny money but sort of those
funny moves
um because there's a lot of other things
going on in that market in terms of
hedging
um the edgers you know they'll do it
during the day not necessarily at night
but some of these moves at night on the
hikanashi chart are
pretty stable to say you know putting it
mildly nice moves up nice move down nice
moves up
um again this is the
this is from the reopen here
at five you know this is the Asian hours
you know going back the day before you
know again some decent moves during the
day but again if you can't trade during
the day
you know
look at these moves at night
okay let's move down a little by here
move down
buy and sell back and forth moves down
moves down
all right so
it's
again you know the value scalper
right it's it's designed to look for
equilibrium in the market right what
appears to be value at one moment may no
longer appear to be value
over the next moment okay so again
whether you're looking at you know on
over five minute periods 10 minute
periods yeah it's value is shifting
right and the value scalper it looks for
these shifts in value when price is
moving away from value and it's going to
start to search for new value because
that's what the markets do they're
always searching for Value that's why
you know you see
uh
oh where's my charge
you know
sometimes you know the market sort of
just sort of rotate around here
it's found a value right then it starts
to move away from value
forms a new value starts to move away
from that forms another value starts to
move away from that
it forms another value right that's
that's what you know you see the markets
move pause move pause move pause move
pause it's found its balance right it's
those the opportunity arises
when markets move away from value when
you're trading inside value
the opportunities are much smaller
there's still opportunities when the
market is Trading
inside of value but the bigger
opportunities come when markets move
away from value
right and that's what value scalper is
designed to do it's designed to find
that it's looking for this equilibrium
right one person's perceived value of
the market doesn't match up with another
person's perceived value right because
again you know it's not everybody trades
the same time frame like the same type
of charge not everybody out there
trading trades a five minute chart or a
15-minute chart no I mean I know guys
they don't even look at the charts they
just
know where price is
and there's such longer terminal they
have this macro view of the market oh
what where are we at right now they're
not looking at it relative to something
else that they they have their own
measures of value right so it's not like
everybody's looking at the same sort of
the same chart type right and says okay
this is where we Define it no you know
somebody may be looking at a daily chart
and they Define value differently then
obviously someone looking at a five
minute chart
but when there's that disequilibrium
when that's why you have to be able to
determine where some where value was
formed
because it's when it starts to move away
from that
value that was just formed that's where
the opportunities arise right and that's
what trading is all about it's about
recognizing
that hey you know what we just formed
some value here now we're starting to
move away from it okay so again
if you understand order flow you know
maybe you could understand where value
is right if you're a profile Trader you
understand the concept of value
and again it's not about
you know just taking every trade right
you want to take the trades where you
have follow-through order flow right
that's why we have that
you know the trade entry signal right
that's why you see it's not trading
taking any trades in here
just because it's not really you're not
getting that follow-through order flow
right you want that follow through order
flow so you can catch that move from 64
down to 50 you know down into the 50s as
opposed to maybe taking along here at 49
it going only up to 50 and a half and
then coming out here and stopping you
out at 48.
right or taking along here right and
just goes up a little bit and then stops
you out or taking along here and stops
you out you want those ones those those
clear trades where the market is you
know moving in that direction
and jump on it right get in on those
trades
um all right guys so I'm going to take a
look at some questions here will that
work on range bars
yes it will
um let me just go here
uh change this to a range
base chart I mean I don't know what to
use for e-minis anymore I used to use
an eight range
I used to use a four range and an eight
range chart
um but it's a little bit uh
more volatile these days so again this
is what the setting at
two
I'd keep it at three
and honestly I'd probably start with uh
some sort of
swing filter on here
you know because this is a range based
chart
again I don't know what range you're
looking at but um
you know just sort of go back in here I
mean it does catch this nice move here
some small moves down in here it's
the the
thing with range based charts is
sometimes
they can move very fast right that's why
yeah I'm not sure what range people use
nowadays it's one of those things where
it's like
you know I used to use an eight range
chart back in you know 2014 2015 and
on an eight range chart sometimes you
could spend 20 minutes forming one bar
whereas now you see this is a 10 range
chart and it's taken you know
less than 30 seconds to form a bar so it
really depends on on what you're using
but you'd probably want to throw in at
least a
you know a swing filter in my opinion on
there
just to sort of keep it I'll say keep it
honest but
um the last thing you want is you know
signals flying left and right I mean
even adding on a power mode because
again you know sometimes people think
well I'm on a
I'm on a range based chart I'm
I'm not
taking into account time because you're
taking into account price movement yes
but
on volatile markets or volatile times
price moves very quickly so you're not
on a time-based chart you're on a price
moving chart but if price is moving very
quickly you're on a very very quick
chart
so like this is it with you know you can
see here like these buys and sells
you know
this is with power mode with it set to
set the three
again it it really depends on what type
of chart you're looking at you may have
to make some adjustments
um
okay let's take a look at 15 Ryan
foreign
what is the setting let's just sort of
go back and
take off this take off the filters just
have it at three
Okay so
again this is just
with the basic setting of three now
again it's
you're talking this is pretty much the
whole day right here on this screen
now if you were to add you know some
filters
I don't know if I think if you set it to
one you're going to take out a lot
so with the swing filter of one yeah I
think it cleans it up
a bit you're still catching some of
these
major moves here this obviously this
move down this will move up
let's move down here
and that's what the swing filter I've
wanted if you set it at three swing
filter at I don't know set it at five I
think I'm gonna take out
a bunch more trades here
let's take a look
okay yeah when he cleans it up but it
takes out
quite a few of the trades
let's just take a look at uh
power mode we'll set it I don't know at
one
start out there
okay
catches that move up and catches this
but just goes sideways this one goes
sideways a little bit of a move down
there this one goes sideways so again
you know it's something you'd have to
sort of figure out but again that's just
one day that's just
Friday
the day before it's a nice moves in the
evening session
this was the day before this was
Thursday you know Thursday was a nice
move up nice move down
this one again is coming 10 minutes
before the cash close up here
you know you're going back from the
evening session on Thursday
morning this is Thursday at three in the
morning
you know from 70 39 77
your first Buy Signal comes down here at
uh 22. that's a 50 point move right
there
I mean I'll be honest with you anytime
you get a nice methodical Trend like
this
any
I think any indicator should at least
catch allow you to catch most of that
move and you can see here just as it's
coming out of this balance area
the signals are coming in again this is
with the setting of
power mode
and a value level of one
um see Deborah asks how many bars is
this looking back is why are we buying
bars and
It's a combination
um
this is like V web yeah it's how many
the question is how many bars is this
looking back
well it looks back over at least
minimum of two
but there's more that goes into it than
that than just the two bars but it
is how you're gonna it's not just
necessarily looking for Value in in one
bar all the time
um
is there an option how many bars are
reading before signal generated
kind of well I mean okay for example
well there's
two ways one is you could obviously
enable a swing filter to give it you
know a
more of a look back right that would you
know if you were to set a swing filter
of
um
you know for example called
10 okay I'll take this off power mode
it's gonna give you it's going to take
into account more activity
I don't know how it's going to look here
so you can see there's a cell here by
here it buys and sells there this is on
the the range based chart
um
is this like view app or is it like
total value area between no it's not
like view app or total value or it's
it's reading what's happening
in a shorter time period right in a
shorter time period
as opposed to you know your your profile
on the side that's take into account the
whole day
um
you know there's
so for example uh let's just go take a
look at some things here some other
type of tools so for example
not this one um
right there are tools out there that you
could have that
show you some things you know it's sort
of a rolling profile or a ninjatrader
has this
profile box okay
again I don't really want to talk about
this indicator here but
um
really what your
your if you have a
just you know for example right if you
were to draw
this is our little
here right you have this sort of from
your swing low up to the swing High okay
you have a value area in here
okay
all right that's this area
so you know you want to be looking for
signs that you know we're forming this
value right and as you sort of
whoops I can actually adjust it here for
that how to do this here we go
right you can see here right from this
swing low up to this swing High
your value is is more or less the same
now you're coming down you're testing
your value area low here
and you're getting some signs of
uh say rejection but it's coming down
it's testing this value area low of this
period from your swing low to your swing
High
and if it's not going to go down any
further from the swing low you know then
you're going to look forward to Rally up
okay but again
the value scalper doesn't use a tool
like this but I mean that's how you
would sort of make you know similar
decisions based off of doing it manually
right there's things that the value
scalper looks at that is going to tell
you hey you know what it's rejecting
this this value area
but again if you want to be plotting
your own value areas and then
calculating things of you know signs
like this of these rejections yeah okay
you can just as
you know here
right came down in here sort of trading
below the value area there's the value
area low it's rejecting that you know
then Works its way back up because we
know that
you know it's been discussed at length
in by many excellent Traders out there
that you come down into a value area low
or value area high and reject that you
can make a move all the way to the other
side of value
and even go on Beyond it
so anyway
um I'll end it there for today guys it's
again thanks for taking the time out of
your Sunday morning
I know it's uh
you know it's that holiday week and I
wanted to get this out sooner rather
than during the week when we're all busy
running around preparing for
Thanksgiving
so again you know if you're interested
in the value scalper you just go to you
know I'll put the link here in the chat
the Link's on your email but it's just
uh
www dot value scalper.com
okay and
you know just this is the link value
scalper.com and yeah I I
I I threw a lot of charts on this page I
I think I might have thrown too many
that might be slow for people to load
but I really want you guys to understand
you know
how robust I'll say robust but you know
in many different markets right yes
right bonds I showed you Ultra bonds
right this is bonds
nice moves again you know you don't have
to trade minis you don't have to trade
mnq there's so many other great markets
out there to trade
um you know this is crude oil right here
you can with the power mode on you see
how it
cleaned it up quite nicely gives you
nice signals there right
gold gold
even again I don't look at many stocks I
do follow Apple I think Apple's a nice
proxy for the markets
um mini Dao right we need now the next
day
euro currency
British pound right so again you just
click on that button there it's just
only 279 it's great uh little tool to
add to your trading Arsenal so on that
uh have a great Thanksgiving everybody
and
hope to hear from you bye-bye